Miette man you are just came into a very
fancy restaurant welcome eating my
eighth i had my two beautiful baited
made thank you thank you
so I got really drunk and I got really
hungry and then I fell asleep so what
you're getting is pitch-black cold
french fries and chicken nuggets but all
you can eat all we can eat oh my gosh
you know what is that over there on the
side there's like I see like some fries
yeah there's there's some champagne
champagne isn't that free dang it okay
so the next item deep fried stick beans
chips and eggs on Facebook is on top of
Facebook yeah we it does not look that
bad I don't understand in West this is
food porn right you know it's got to be
a little attractive to someone some
people have low standards game so I
don't know how I know you deep fried
steak on top there it looks kind of red
I know that ketchup that's how we have
it in your of we have it red we don't
ever cook a steak like stupid though I
mean is that very oh damn we're in the
corner by the frost what is it maybe a
little bit maybe a little they care to
know
Jen I would you say would you like to
stake would you perhaps like what jump
against can I can I get it medium where
possible you know what
okay I'll let's see what else we get
there are some high Calicut cat shark
[ __ ] sure good daily cutie would you
like some chef batali well what exactly
is charcuterie
it's a salami some pie and some cheese
Oh some Sunda plate you know honestly I
honestly I have that plate did you did
you get like some packaged salami and
some packaged cheese and like a half a
piece of bread and throw it on there
maybe I
you with my do we have something sick
what do you have like just like some hot
dogs no just too good we let me see her
in the back so this is the finest french
toast
avec own cheese and uh turn and tomato
ketchup there's not Felix tomato ketchup
because [ __ ] that plain tomato ketchup
have you have you ever tried a hot dog
on a french toast no I have I cannot say
that the delicacy I've had the honour to
trying away away anywhere today is your
lucky day
angled I may or may not absorb them on
this planet okay let's see yeah for
jihad we have what the [ __ ]
yes anti-diabetic grande as I like to
call it yeah Alberto Grande no LT a
better LD LD upload run day no LT a
better you get diabetes it's oh the
devil Alberto okay hey you do it you
don't understand you guys actually looks
pretty interesting I guess I want to try
it
the diabetes okay we got like the
biscuit spread fluff cookie spread and
Eminem's all in a burrito the most
American thing I've seen in my life
there's no way I could eat that without
throwing up phone of rainbows you means
it's so delicious and now you're
finished now you pay me and you go oh
how much is it are you on the baby I'm
the man you like you let us know here
the one that invited us to your basement
I have 55 my pocket $20,000 $20,000 yes
yes girlie Nelly [ __ ] from fights you
have a deal sir oh thank you and please
come again to the no I sent to the book
game okay can't wait to get a speci
overview